I am in Iceland it is both stunningly
beautiful and stunningly cold and it's
also a very good place to talk about
something you might not know which is
names specifically how a lot of the
world's names perhaps even the majority
don't fit into the English system of
names given to you by your parents and
then names inherited from your parents
here in Iceland for example the idea
that you have a family name handed down
generation to generation to generation
just doesn't happen it's rare at best
instead children take their parents
first name with son or daughter attitude
which incidentally might say Icelandic
telephone Darrent a little bit
complicated you have to index by first
name and by occupation because there are
so few last names in total and if that
sounds strange we'll think of all the
people you know whose last names are
going to be Thomson or Davidson or
Peterson or Jamison all of those are
that Icelandic system which used to be
the English system it's just changed now
so it is a family name and beyond that
you have all the people who don't go by
their legal name technically even I
don't my legal name is Thomas Scott but
I go by Tom add to that the people who
go by their middle name or who go by a
nickname or who just go by a different
name for any number of reasons then
you've got the cultures who put their
family name first which is always
confusing when they're trying to
translate over to English which brings
me to a bit of advice really um if
you're asking for people's names either
on a paper form or online don't put
first name and last name
don't put or the worst case Christian
name and surname just give someone a box
to type in to just ask them what their
name is and for bonus points they ask
them how they want to be addressed
because well if you want to make friends
the best way is to get someone's name
right
you